my wife is from spain cucumber
cucumbers i'm born in boston as a source
tells e.t
she and her family are quote very upset
that her identity
and background are being questioned the
harassment and hate that she has been
receiving on social media has been a lot
for her with everything that is going on
with my sister-in-law i feel terrible
singer chyna phillips just addressed the
scandal as her husband
alex brother billy baldwin was quoted
saying this is probably an
awkward and embarrassing time none of us
are perfect
and like we all have issues
and we all have our thing however we're
told alec has quote
always known that ellaria is from boston
and unconditionally supports and loves
ellaria our source
even points to her tweet from 2012
listing her u.s birthplace
i spent some of my childhood in boston
some of my childhood in spain
as for that bio posted in 2014 that
listed ellaria's birthplace as mallorca
spain
that was done by her agents our source
says it was not something she had
ever seen it was filled with multiple
inaccuracies
now to laurie lachlan going back to
acting i forgot how needy you are
a source tells et that the 56 year old
actress who was released from prison one
week ago
has been quote finding it very difficult
to not worry about massimo
however she's also been talking about
getting her life back
our source says lori one day would love
to start working again but she is scared
people won't work with her she has had
her team put out feelers
and finally larry king hospitalized with
covet 19. who knows
what the future's going to bring the 87
year old host is reportedly at cedar
sinai medical center in la
after battling the virus for about 10
days and has been moved
out of the icu i was not too far from a
stroke et's been with larry through many
health issues
including a stroke lung cancer and a
heart attack back in 1987.
anybody who's had bypass surgery in and
heart attack thinks about mortality a
[Music]
lot